when you look at the state of Georgia as
the world economy changed and shifted I
don't think our government really
reacted in the way that it should have
in terms of preparing the citizens to be
able to be equipped to be successful so
I'm very concerned about rural America
in 2016 president Trump won the
Republican dominated state of Georgia
with about 51 percent of the vote in
2020 the state of seed is competitive in
part due to a rise in black voter
participation while only 8 percent of
black voters cast their ballot for
president Trump in 2016
his reelection campaign is betting that
a small boost in several battleground
states like Georgia can also help keep
him in office blacks for Trump as Trump
tries to increase his appeal with
African Americans and the attention on
black voters in the deep south increases
we drove south from Atlanta about an
hour to half to Fort Valley where we sat
down with eight black voters from across
middle Georgia the group was split
between Democrats and Republicans
unlike the broader black electorate
which overwhelmingly votes Democratic we
did this to better understand what
voters from both parties are concerned
about heading into the 2020 election
raise your hand if you voted for Barack
Obama in 2008 keep your hand up if you
voted for begin in 2012 we lost John and
raise your hand if you voted for Donald
Trump in 2016 John I want to start with
you who were for Obama in 2008 I know
you supported Donald Trump in 2016
can you talk a little bit about what
appeal to you about President Trump when
I started looking at the Democratic
Party and the Republican Party it kind
of seemed like our government lost touch
with the people and so I felt like many
that hey we needed a bull in the china
shop and I didn't elect President Trump
or support president Trump because he
had kouf because he was had etiquette no
I I wanted a gangster and in the daggone
White House to just wreck shop I wanted
to talk about political correctness or
identity politics
in the country I'm very concerned about
that in the society because we are being
catered to based on our so-called
identity and they we're not anymore
talking about what Martin Luther King
talked about character we're not talking
about that anymore
it's skin it's religion the least
important thing about a person as far as
I'm concerned is what they look like Oh
what they claim to be Veronica you were
you were shaking her head when she was
talking about political correctness do
you think our PC culture as they call it
has gone too far in some ways I do I
think that it creates a lack of
opportunity for us to really get to know
each other
I really believe civility is taking a
hit and so how can we sit amongst our
selves as we're doing here and you know
we may disagree with policy or we may
disagree with you know what other people
are saying but you don't have to label
folks as a bad person because you don't
agree with with how they view the world
I'm black so it's automatically assumed
that I am a Democrat it's automatically
assumed that I'm gonna vote on a lot of
things but when I tell people that I'm a
pro black conservative they get
cross-eyed who has heard president Trump
say black people should support me
because what do they have to lose
otherwise people here you've heard that
yeah what did you all think of that I
would disagree we can't do revisionist
history we have to make sure that we
recognize the unique journey that we as
African Americans have traveled in the
United States and that's been a very
difficult journey I was born in 1969
Civil Rights Act in 1964 Voting Rights
Act in 65 so when we say well we don't
have anything to lose we have a lot to
lose I wanted to ask about voters
here in Georgia that there's Democrats
prominently who are claiming that
there's voter suppression going on in
the state in there are Republicans who
push back on that pretty forcefully can
we do the short hands again of who
thinks that there is systematic voter
suppression in the state of Georgia they
sent all these letters out in the black
community to discourage them from voting
and all kind of things
Linda you're shaking your head I mean
you know you're thinking and I've seen
people like that you I know you had bad
experiences coming back from Nam there
was discrimination I realize all of that
you know I mean but you're just thinking
you know white people they want to cute
a black man down you know no don't
I mean I'm free to go and vote people
who say that institutionally the
government here is racist in that is why
you have voter suppression I think
that's where the racist my point is
there is no voter suppression as such
this smaller suppression correct the
people don't show up to vote that
machine that tells you that they have
not show up to vote you think the
Machine you knows that color the person
I believe that we should have a holiday
for people to be able to vote well just
if there's a lot of people aren't voting
because they can't get off work to vote
and then in some rural communities there
may be some long Geographic distances
that you have to travel in order to be
able to vote I want to bring John in
because you guys agreed on on that and
is that something that you would support
if a presidential candidate toss it out
a national voting day I would support
that because I stood on top of a Humvee
in another country for people to vote I
do believe that in our country we should
be able to create an atmosphere where
voting is easy for legal Americans every
legal American should have the right to
vote and if that means having a holiday
for people to to make it easy so that
way we can take away the excuses of
nobody we had
being able to vote yeah and then let's
do it you support it Donald Trump in
2016 we didn't get to vote for him right
could you kind of talk about what
happened in what solutions you think
might have helped you our voting and how
we vote is very difficult I moved from
Columbus to Milledgeville and I wanted
to vote for Donald Trump
I wasn't suppressed it just was too
convoluted that's what advocates like
Veronica here would say it's just that
those types of red tape
disproportionately affects black people
I didn't feel like there was some like
agenda because hey you're black and we
want to like slow your vote I just felt
like the whole system what happened to
me could happen to anybody regardless of
being black or white or Asian or
Hispanic you feel like the candidates
are talking enough about voter
suppression no for those of you who
believe that it's happening I don't
think they're talking enough about it if
it doesn't affect you you don't bring it
up and that's where it is if it doesn't
affect your people you don't bring it up
and that gets us a little bit to the
lack of diversity in the field right now
for the Democrats here we started out
with a very diverse field and now we've
seen some very prominent minorities drop
out of the Democratic races how
disappointing is that for you I'm
disappointed but those that again
I'm for who is plans to have vote for
Joe Biden in the Democratic primary okay
that's three who else do you guys like
that are planning to vote in the
Democratic primary I'm definitely
considering Bernie Sanders somewhat I'm
concerned with how it will get done but
we'll never know if we never try I'm
concerned with being a college student
who's also independent that I may not be
able to afford health care but I'm
trying to also get a four-year degree
now who's gonna see about me I want to
go to Howard and just talk about you put
your hand up kind of slow for Joe Biden
are you completely sold on him are you
waiting already
Democrat and Joe Biden would be my
choice there doesn't mean that's who I'm
gonna vote for for president in the
election and so can you kind of walk us
through if it's Joe Biden versus Donald
Trump in the general election
what your decision-making process would
be as it's saying now or Trump looks
looks attractive I've made it clear I
don't like Trump but I'm looking for
what's best for the country when it
comes to trade for a minute there trade
was looking pretty dim but not starting
to look a little brighter because he put
demands down and I do not consider that
to be one of the things that I
appreciate him for you support Joe Biden
yes I support Joe Biden because I I
associate with electability with Joe
Biden when anybody can just consider
Elizabeth Warren for any Democrat that
wins the nomination the best person I
think my heart is a little bit worn but
I don't think she could win why because
America hadn't reached a stage of voting
for women I think I'm wrong but why do
you both say that I'm just curious the
older generation are the main ones still
voting and if you look back in history
it's like they don't really think a
woman should be in charge we go back
into identity politics again you know I
don't care whether they're man or women
we're looking for someone who can do the
actual job who would vote for a woman
now keep your hand up if you think a
woman could win the White House why did
you put your hand up like you would vote
for a woman but you think she couldn't
win because literally we've seen that
here in history if you want to use
Hillary Clinton for example she was she
wasn't she wasn't she was a former first
lady I voted for Hillary Clinton just
because she had a lifetime in politics
not just some person who jumped out of
somewhere and just said okay I want to
run for president who do you think can
bring people out I think that a lot of
people will think on the Democratic side
like mr. Dinard
that whoever is a Democrat they're gonna
go out and support that person because
they are voting against Trump and then
on the other side they will go out and
vote against the Democrat right so I'm
not seeing as much allegiance to a
candidate per se but against a candidate
what are some reforms to the criminal
justice system you'd like to see happen
I would like to see all people who have
been locked up for minor drug offenses
just to make sure that that is white I
think that we need to to look at how
we've locked up a lot of people for
something that we now don't see as a as
a criminal offense I just I just think
that we criminalize too many too many
things does anyone disagree with that
stance I disagree because I work in a
forensic facility with people who have
criminal backgrounds and I am not in
favor of people just having their
records expunged for so-called minor
offenses marijuana selling marijuana
it's in the schools and everything
that's not a minor offense drugs or
drugs
I know there's the big push on about
legalizing it I'm not for that and I see
a lot of people who get out of prison
they go right back in they could they
get out they commit crimes recidivism
rate I mean there's a reason for that
and I just want to ask what harm is
marijuana doing a lot Veronica can you
kind of talk about some struggles you
wish politicians would address that they
feel like they're not addressing right
now I would start with K through 12
education and the fact that I think that
we're not funding public education in
the way that it needs to be funded I
don't think that the autonomy is there
for local decision-making so that these
schools can be unique they can prepare
our students for a global economy and I
think we have a very antiquated approach
to higher education right
we have some wonderful public
institutions in Georgia and I would love
to see them receive more funding than
they have if we're really serious about
pulling everybody along so that we all
can be successful then that starts with
how we prepare people to launch into
into this world I think that for too
long no matter which president no matter
which party is in office education gets
a lot of you know it gets a lot of buzz
it gets a lot of talk but progress is
not really made in it um in how you
judge progress when you say that I judge
progress on well for me personally just
things that I see right around me
locally
I see education has having failed for
decades now I agree with Veronica with
saying that education really deserves
more autonomy personally I would love to
see the Department of Education
dissolved one of the things that I
dislike about the Democratic Party is
why is there always the fight about
charter schools or school choice since
you pay taxes why can't you have the
option of sending your child to another
school and that is always fought I think
that some Democrats would argue that the
more students you pull out of failing
schools when you do a head count to
figure out how many how much money per
head is gonna go to the school it the
school will get even worse if any of you
agree with that or do I assume maybe
Linda you disagree with that if a school
is failing why would you want to leave
your child there it should fail it
should be closed I come from one of
those failing school systems and I'm a
product of it I believe I turned out all
right I learn how to create my own
opportunities but even now I still
believe I have I have to give back
because coming from those communities
you know how it feels to go without you
know how it feels when people are never
calling pulling your car to call him
your name so I feel like that's how we
move forward as a nation
we can't just care about where we are we
have to see about everybody as as
America we are a democratic nation
that's so I feel like if one part of the
nation is failing then we're failing as
a whole
[Music]